ironically LSD first emerged from the
heart of the system it was synthesized
in 1938 by Swiss chemist Albert Hoffman
in the Laboratories of what would later
become Pharma giant Novartis and used by
psychiatrists and therapists to treat
alcoholism and depression
some of its most enthusiastic early
adopters worked for the CIA in the 1950s
the agency typically without consent
dosed its own employees soldiers
prisoners and mental patients with LSD
as part of an experimental mind control
program called MK Ultra convinced that
Soviet and Chinese Communists had
developed brainwashing techniques U.S
intelligence agencies wanted to make
sure that Americans had equal or better
tools